I don't know hardly I don't really get
bullied do you don't get bullied it's
good you don't go outside do you no I
mean thank you no one really bullies me
like seriously like people will like
lightheartedly kind of but no come to my
face and been like screamed at me or
anything like that he also grew up in
Arcadia too right in that area but I
mean like he's talking about like a show
like I've never been in that situation
no one's ever spoken to you
condescendingly cuz maybe I'm just a
sensitive [ __ ] and it's probably not
that bad but then I might take it that
bad but I just don't like people raising
their voice I mean yeah talk
condescendingly to my girlfriend and
that kind of triggers me but oddly no
one really does that to me I mean very I
mean I don't I can't really remember
like David kind of makes fun of me like
you guys but it's like it's not like no
no cuz we're friends aggressive kind of
like I feel threatened kind of way yeah
you know why maybe because you don't do
things so for example like if you're in
that group right you would have just
waited until you got orders instead of
just saying well [ __ ] you and you walked
away so yeah things that maybe upset
yeah people probably also do is because
we are comics so people feel like they
could joke around with that when they
don't have that rapport with us right
and that's where a lot of the times that
that kind of [ __ ] goes awry also to is
because we put ourselves out there in
that type of sense so people feel like
they have to match that energy when they
really don't have to right we're there's
this online personality there's this
camera personality and yeah I'm very
similar to my camera personality but
it's like those are performance parts
right and sometimes people kind of they
blur those lines a lot and it causes a
lot of problems and frictions like for
example like well is that a show and we
were taking this photo right you know
I'm like a joking ass do I joke around a
lot and you know I give people hugs or
whatever this dude as we were taking
this photo he comes up and as we're
taking the photo he [ __ ] grabs my ass
immediately I slapped him upside then
did you [ __ ] bulb slap his face I
slapped him upside the head falling from
the blocking force that he was I don't
[ __ ] touch me dude did what did he he
apologized
but I was pissed I was like because he's
trying to be funny right and it's like
if Bart touched my ass
that's okay I know bar doesn't my
brother you know what I mean you don't
touch me like that I don't [ __ ] know
you dude
like it's like that same concept of like
would you touch a girl like that you
probably wouldn't and if you did you
probably should get [ __ ] up too but
people blur those lines a lot right
because they're too comfortable yeah a
little too comfortable you know that
makes sense because if someone came up
and grabbed my ass that would just be
really random would just be like they
would just have something wrong with
them like yeah wouldn't be
understandable with you I kind of get it
is it gonna be funny yeah like hey buddy
yeah let's do gay jokes yeah yeah that's
that's really what it is and you know
I'm like and it wasn't like I thought
about slapping just automatic lights
went by this is what I would do reflex
I just [ __ ] squeeze my ass thank you
but like what the [ __ ] was that about
feel good honestly it felt like a trump
grope like a skunk
like a claw you know what I mean I feel
like some people do that [ __ ] though to
like get you to remember them hmm I
don't even remember his face I don't
remember anything about him I just like
you're the guy slept if he told me like
I'm the guy that grabbed your ass then I
probably member him but if I don't
remember his face at all whatsoever at
all it's hard to remember people men cuz
you meet so many people there's somebody
that I I saw recently now this person I
know that I had rapport with her and cuz
I probably I did a college show enough
times with her there that I met her a
couple of times I think she was one of
the organizers that brought me out well
she lives in LA now and I saw her I see
her a couple of times around this area
like that I live in and no idea what the
[ __ ] she is but she knows who I am so
every time I see her I'd have to
introduce I don't remember her name I
don't know what college I saw her from
and I don't know why we have such good
rapport well it's hard because in one
meet-and-greet you'd meet someone well
there's three to eight hundred people
that show up sometimes yeah so you try
giving that kind of attention and then
remembering someone that you met for
about one minute maybe two minutes max
it's difficult dude yeah even even if
you have interactions with like an event
organized a organ organizer that like
brought you out or whatever and you
spend a day with them right like we're
meeting thousands of people every year
so and on top of that they don't know
how much drugs I've done yeah a lot of
the times I'm like I'm sorry I don't
remember you but like I'm it's not
because I'm mr. famous it's because I
have bad memory
dude let's aside I think I went to a
Knicks boxing thing maybe like four
times before I remembered like the other
guy's name yeah it's cuz yes I just
don't remember you have to really put it
to memory yes we're just kind of like in
the multi the multiple times like see
how I've learned to do it now it's like
if I really vibe with somebody at a show
and I'm like oh we could be friends when
I take the contact in my phone I give
them a nickname like there's no one
wrong name is yeah so it'll be like
Jessica [ __ ] eyes she's not even Asian
it helps you remember why she had really
really tiny eyes and she was from
Alabama like I remember so I'll put the
college that they were from like some
kind of physical attribute that I
remember about them or something weird
that they did and then it helps me
remember them a lot because I'll tell
them like yo when you hit me up and if
you ever come to LA y'all show up we'll
go grab a meal because you were so
hospitable towards me when I went there
so I but I have to do that I have to be
like James bad breath Kim people take
you up on that not a lot I think they're
maybe they're a little apprehensive
about it but the hard part is when
people come when I go out to a show I'm
yours right because that's what I'm
there did yeah but when I'm here I'm
still working yeah so it's it's hard to
kind of match it's hard because I feel
bad when friends come visit LA and I
can't give them the same type of like
hospitality that they give me when I'm
in their city cuz um it's like it's like
our buddy Nancy from Hawaii right like
every time we're in Hawaii she's like
always hanging out with us driving us
around like and then for us when she
comes down like I could probably meet up
for like a dinner or two but then I
can't do the same thing where I'm like
hanging out with her yeah and that's the
same for a lot of people and I'm like
man that kind of it kind of sucks
because I feel like I'm not being a
girlfriend yeah where I can do the same
amount of effort and it's only because
when we're in LA
like we're just close to our work so
close that like our regular lives don't
allow that yeah yeah because for you and
you do music I mean first of all you
were an accountant first before you
became an audition right which is such a
weird from numbers to love yeah that's
such a weird trajectory did you were you
always singing since you were little
kiddos I saw no it happened I started
singing in a senior year end of senior
year in high school
aurelion how'd you figure that out I was
terrible I was singing I just wanted a
creative way to ask this girl to prom
and I know really bad singing yeah why
did you just [ __ ] ask her because all
the pictures right and then I would like
tiptoe again in the picture I would like
you know like you do the thing where
you're like you